service s kids und herzlich willkommen
zu einer neuen serie
die serie heißt road to top ten und
worum es geht das sieht eher nach dem
intro
so dass wir wieder und jetzt ein paar
erklärende worte road to top ten ist
englisch und steht für weg in die top 10
und bei top 10 geht es natürlich um die
ender gamestop sehen ihr wisst ja in der
gems beliebten spielmodus und ich hab
mir gedacht stärken wir doch einfach mal
eine serie in der wir beide ich und ihr
zuschauer zusammen sozusagen den weg
bestreiten in die top ten in ender games
wir schauen gerade mal wir sind jetzt
auf platz 104 und um das sozusagen
erfolgreich zu gestalten habe ich mir
natürlich tatkräftig unterstützen geholt
und zu habe ich jetzt magic fand dabei
günstig an wo der sender games können
damals knapp hier platz zwei belegt also
der junge hat auch schon ein bisschen
ahnung und ich freue mich richtig drauf
endlich mal wieder so eine kleine serie
auf meinem channel und das war ein
richtig schlechter anfang sloot und ja
ich glaube das wird ultra geil wenn ihr
bock drauf habt könnt ihr euch schon mal
dass in die kommentare schreiben
ja wir die gleiche geste oder ein
leichter lassen
ihr wollt vor allen dingen junge junge
herr ludwig die sachen rechner seien ja
vor allen dingen wenn ich aufhöre hatte
sogar vergeblich auch gar nicht bis g
pop ist erwarte ich guck mal was findest
du dir ja viele
ok dann macht ihm schwer alles klar
auf jeden fall in dieser serie wisag
wird es darum gehen dass ich versuche
den weg in den top ten zu schaffen und
ich denke mal ich war zu alle fünf
plätze vielleicht ein video machen weil
fünf plätze können sie am ende richtig
ziehen oder naja also da brauchst schon
später mal über 1000 fans auf jeden fall
das wird abenteuerlich aber ich denke
dass wir es schaffen zusammen und europa
dabei ist dass ihr mir in die kommentare
schreiben könnt welche kids ihr sehen
wollt schreibt der vater jedes video im
nächsten video spiel doch bitte mal das
kit zum beispiel crafter oder delfin und
dann schaue ich mir die kommentare an
und macht es dann natürlich entsprechend
und spielt diese kids und ich hab jetzt
kurzfristig kirchen älter
wir legen jetzt einfach mal los hier und
schauen wir dass man sich wieder hinten
snacken den hier oft hat es bist du ja
war nichts weiter sobald der gestellt
du hast ein reiner den einbettet und ich
habe den anderen mitteln okay okay gut
so lief das alles klar dass ein 8
wenn ich hast du bist du ich guck mal da
unten
minute noch ein bisschen weiter so
wurden die switch auch passaus wir
wurden mit switch einen apfel essen und
ich glaube das könnte eine richtig geile
sache werden ich bin echt zuversichtlich
dass wir das schaffen
weil ich in letzter zeit ändern games
doch recht intensiv spiele
manche würden sagen suchte aber das ist
natürlich vollkommen übertrieben
dudu alters denkt dass ich das hat mir
gereicht fakten spieler hat sehr hoch
ist ich will bogen ich will da oben
roters mache ich so gerne
die kassen bogen bleibt immer eine
plattform gebaut
ja gut ich hab ich habe mich aufpassen
als rat hatte mir in der schweiz arbeite
da hingelegt
da kommt jemand runter zugegeben bei
schalten sehr gestorben okay auch kein
das sieht das hat sich das gleiche bild
ich mache mich meiner ich nämlich in den
themen
das hat mich gerettet das finde ich ja
nicht hofer alter [ __ ] ich bin alter hat
nicht aufgepasst scheiße läuft bei uns
auf jeden fall sagt hast du hast so
apple
neben stephanie aber wir müssen auch ein
bisschen auseinander damit unsere
kompass funktionieren uns zu warnen
genau so zac so wir machen das auch
schnell ein crafting table meist macek
ob jemand in der nähe ist es weit weg
der die beats magic tun so alles klar
da mit dem zweiten platz was halb
zweiter platz wie brain after kann man
sein warum kam habe ich jetzt grad
zweiter platz gesehen weil ich mich die
hänge ich habe wirklich keine ahnung
warum ich kein zweiter platz gesagt habe
krasse scheiße sowas habe ich echt zählt
dass ich mich komplett sinnvolle sind
sinnlose sachen soll weiß also eine
tolle sachen sound blaster mich jetzt
ist er mich wird's ein bisschen aus hier
es gibt noch zwei gegner und wir können
uns dann ja sozusagen im deathmatch in
den epic geben
passt auch die elegance
aber leider habe ich nicht mal die rats
für das op das heißt du hast jetzt schon
neuen rüstungs punkten ja doch irgendwie
lag die sache ja so ein bisschen seltsam
wenn deine aufnahme wegen meiner haut
ist meine aufnahme kannst dich liegen
das liegt wahrscheinlich daran dass
draußen einen regenwurm hustet vorm
fenster auch ich habe den getrackt ok
jetzt ist roman [ __ ] ich weiß nicht
ob jetzt roman alter hatte ich in welche
richtung gegangen
ich glaube ich gar nicht glauben dir
keine ahnung ich muss auch schauen dass
wir auf jeden fall noch ein gegner ok
fakt dass es schon vorbei also das hier
ist jetzt gerade die runde
für platz 100 würde ich mal sagen wir
sind sondern nicht genau auf platz 104
aber ich denke mal das könnte mir
verzeihen und die nächste runde kommt
dann wenn ihr bock drauf habt wie gesagt
bei platz 95 oder 90 das ist mir noch
überlegen
ich glaube das wird einfach mega
interessant weil wir so gemeinsam
achtermann drei äpfel wieder gemeinsam
ja sozusagen diesen diesen weg da
bestreiten können und so gemeinsam dazu
lernen auch in der games ich spiele
schon eine weile aber noch lange kann
ich da nicht alles was muss man auch so
sagen ich glaube das wird eine ziemlich
geile sache und warum es nach immer
gegenseitig kennen oder ich weiß nicht
was die andere tut dem romand wird es
hier habe ich habe logitech habe häufig
alles klar ich gerne drauf ich hab ja
nicht ob ich hab ihn keine last comments
nein doch mittels romantisches echt ja
da kommt aber in welche richtung city
herr lass uns mal wieder dran wo alte
geilen team für den ende denn es ist ja
auch spannend dass ich auch noch nie
gesehen krass was ist team durch ja ein
ende games habe ich gejobbt eigentlich
das habe ich das habe ich noch nie
gesehen dass mannschaften hier sions und
power.com level 1 enchantment gas und
power hat man sowieso immer das hat er
ist halt echt geil bei den bögen finde
ich dass man einfach immer power kriegt
meine airline verkantet denn auf fett
pro portion so eine scheiße scheiße
übrigens hier gerade in war wo habe ich
auch gesagt dass sie sich unbedingt ein
power zwei oder drei bogen machen soll
weil der max bekanntlich an maßnahmen
kleiner bogens kinder ist und ich glaube
da hat er richtig gute chancen vor allen
dingen der vorteil ist in faro ich
glaube gap oder oder sonic als sehr wohl
nicht bei schönem wetter mit komme
programm aufrecht ist aber gm werde
wahrscheinlich auch in den äther gehen
irgendwann und sich stärke tränke machen
und wenn ein stärke 2 frank hat witz
halt wirklich nicht in den nahkampf mit
ihm gehen mitarbeiter 260 schaden und
also ich werfe ich welche getränke sind
auch über bord werfen schwäche hast du
ja wenn die sowas machen würden naja
dafür auch mal gern dafür für die
werbebande
ich hatte kurzem und [ __ ] ich hatte
den kurz okay ich habe den ich habe den
ich habe den 46 blöcke
es kommen ja ich hab den jetzt auch ganz
mit schrecken warte ich strecke wird
dich um den job wechseln
wir wissen wurde ist als er wollte ich
glaube ich kann man sein
ich habe den krieg ich habe mich
wirklich der sprecher
das ist alles richtig aber vor allem
eine maus grad so gespaßt sind meint
meinen maus finger war ganz so gelähmt
irgendwie ich konnte konnte nicht
schlagen fakt aber okay ich hab ihn
gegeben ins match fand wir sind immer
noch beieinander
ja was ich kann die richtung in die
andere
ja schau mal und ich würde sagen leute
wenn ihr bock auf dieses projekt hat auf
diese serie wo wir gemeinsam in die
top-10 länder games gehen
ich glaube da wenn wir auch sogar damit
dass erste sozusagen team mit dem ersten
youtuber in top 10
also weil ich fand es auch macht ja auch
videos und kann ich auch ich mal die
beschreibung packen
aber so der keine ahnung ja größere hört
sich jetzt dumm einen oder so aber ich
glaube ihr wisst was ich meine
ich glaube es war ziemlich ziemlich geil
das und ich würde sagen wenn ihr bock
drauf habt könnt ihr einfach mal schauen
ob 100 geschafft das war ziemlich geil
und bevorzugen einer seite hin hahn
brauche ich nicht ich werde auch so
machen aber ich finds halt einfach geil
wenn ihr so eure unterstützung zeigt
weil dafür ist sehr gut geeignet und ich
hab jetzt wo man bis jetzt nochmal
[ __ ] kommen wo man es ja der youtuber
einer top ten war haubner
ja aber jetzt gerade es keine toten oder
genau es glaube ich nicht meine tochter
hat als das duo roman hast du denn jetzt
ich habe gab er wieder ganz viele
verloren irgendwie sogar wieder
rangekommen dann wieder weiter weg
ich verstehe das nicht seltsam er sei
wahrscheinlich dass der riss ist gerade
richtig richtig spannend oder wo ist der
typ
ich verstehe das nicht was macht er denn
eine erlebte wohl noch mit nee ich hatte
er hat ihn gerade gecheckt der lebt noch
den fall noch mal hat das hat mir damals
meiner dass das leute die irgendwie so
am markt eigentlich schon tot sind aber
trotzdem tabs angezeigt werden das hallo
ok dann läuft man von mir weg ja noch
mal gerade im weg und ich geh seitlich
so bisschen wir müssen hier noch finden
egal was man noch vielleicht sagen
könnte dass unser first rainer ja auf
jeden fall ja also das liegt ganz gut
wenn man hat eben mit den ersten
aufnahmen versuch gestartet und direkt
so in der nächsten runde raus gehauen
und das von ihr nicht ganz geheuer
sonst hat man es manchmal ja mal dass
man einander games im ein paar versuche
braucht aber wisst ihr was wisst ihr was
sie entscheidend jetzt einfach was hast
du ja warte warte nicht geben
und ich versuche einfach noch schnell zu
dir überzeugt habe wurde ich wollte gar
mit dem switch 3
ja okay bin ich in welche richtung bin
ich jetzt warte ich bin in die richtung
gegangen glaube ich bin in den wald war
mal ein bisschen seitlich weg er immer
alte was ist das was ist das für ein
finale wie ewig manning trekken muss den
vertrag den ich sagte okay dann bei
bestehen ich sehe dich sehen ich sehe
ich sehe ich schleppe ich habe mich
menschen haben mir schnappen
der ist da ist da so prof
hast du angst hast du dir gott behütet
alter muss ich eigentlich mal das lokal
machen weil ich glaube mein fall denn
auch gekillt oder knapp vorbei auf jeden
fall balawender slomo rein und da machen
wir jetzt mal einen schönen entscheid
würde ich sagen hast du hast du dir
einschaltet
nein ich meine dann seine rüstung nein
habe ich nicht
ja okay dann machen wir einfach so juli
da zufällig vorher noch also mit magix
schon ein kleiner händler games pro muss
man sagen aber nach dem was jetzt gesagt
wurde
warten wir noch bissig folge reckt hat
noch zwei herzen also zwei halbe herzen
und dann können wir starten
worauf ist so schnell wunder wenn man
fleisch ist ja okay bis breit 321 co
okay das service im feld von her
das jetzt scheiße kein geld der welt
kann es auch im slogan mach dann mach
ich doch mein ganzes leben in oslo muss
man schauen ob ich dann denke ich treffe
ich mich gut bei euch regel gar nicht
dass das werk vor glück braucht ermessen
ist egal denn wenn es aber auch nicht
mehr schweine kommen
so spannt alter wo ich mit tod und tod
ganz vergessen
jaja paar leute so lange wir einmal den
zweiten der ender games platzierung
liste geschlagen platz zwei und ich
würde sagen ich freue mich die richtig
auf das projekt ich hoffe folglich auch
wir sehen uns beim nächsten video wieder
haut rein lassen positive wertung da
schickt ihn ab dessen der beschreibung
und ciao